We have the examples in South Africa.
Nelson Mandela,
the previous white apathid government
which ruled South Africa. They had
imprisoned Nelson Mandela for 25 years
for more than 25 years in Robin Islands
and they called him terrorist number
one. The white apathid government who
preached that white people are superior
to the other races. They imprisoned
Nelson Mandela for more than 25 years
because he was fighting for the freedom
of the black people for the freedom of
the people of South Africa. Later on
when the white apathided government has
to retrieve Nelson Mandela is released
from Robin Islands. He comes back he
stands in election. He becomes the
president of South Africa. Later on he
gets the Nobel Prize for peace.
Terrorist number one gets the Nobel
Prize for peace. Not that Dennis Mandela
was a bad man, terrorist then he became
a good man for the same activity for
which the South African white apath
government called him a terrorist. He
gets the Nobel Prize for same activity.
After he gets his freedom after he's
elected president of South Africa, the
committee of Nobel Nobel Prize they
award him the Nobel Prize for peace.
Same activity. It's an irony from the
same activity when he was called a
terrorist number one in the world for
the same activity he gets the Nobel
Prize for peace and you have several
examples you have many presidents of
Israel
who terrorized and killed thousands of
people then they get the Nobel Prize for
peace min killed thousands of people was
a TERRORIST HEAD OF A TERRORIST
organization terrorist number one later
on when He becomes the president of
Israel, he gets a Nobel Prize for peace.
What is this? So what we come to know
that whoever is in power,
whoever controls the media, whatever
label they give, it gets stuck. Whoever
is in power, whoever's power, whoever
controls the media, whatever label,
right or wrong gets stuck. So that is
the reason Quran says in surah hujarat
chapter number 49 verse number six
whenever you get information you check
it up before you pass it on to the third
person don't just don't whatever you get
forward you see any news forward it
check it up if you're not sure don't
forward it and we Muslims also most of
our party you see anything you it may be
a fake video it may be a fabrication
today to make a fake video is very easy
So Allah is telling you 1400 years ago
whenever a far gives you a information
whenever a transgressor gives you
information check it up before you pass
it on to someone and lest you may be
involved in spreading the wrong message.
Today you get something you forward it
without checking. Have you checked right
or wrong? So you are becoming a tool of
the Satan. You like it you forward it.
Have you checked it? If you get
something, if you can't verify, don't
spread it. And as I mentioned, one verse
of the Quran, Surah Maida, chapter
number five, verse number 32, is
sufficient to dispel this myth that
Muslims are terrorist. Allah says in the
Quran in surah Maida chapter 5 verse
number 32, if anyone kills any other
human being, unless it be for murder
or for spreading corruption in the land,
it is as though he has killed the whole
of humanity. And if anyone save human
being, it is as though he has saved the
whole nation. See your Quran is very
clearcut. If any human being whether
Muslim or non-Muslim kills any other
human being whether Muslim or non-Muslim
kills any innocent human being whether
Muslim or non-Muslim unless it be for
murder or for spreading corruption in
the land facad in the land it is as
though you have killed the whole of
humanity. And if anyone saves any
innocent human being, it is as though
you have saved the whole of humanity.
This one verse of the Quran of Surah
Maida chapter number 5 verse number 32
is sufficient to dispel this myth that
all terrorists are Muslim.
And for more information as I mentioned
watch my video is terrorism a Muslim
monopoly. How did terrorism start? Who
was the first person who did the first
hijack? who do the kidnapping, suicide,
bombing in detail with statistics from
authentic sources
and more. If you don't know about jihad
terrorism and jihad and Islamic
perspective, these two videos of mine,
if you watch these two lectures, you'll
get ample of ammunition to do dhava.
Ammunition doesn't mean only
gun. Ammunition means material. Here in
context ammunition means material
for conveying the truth to them.